ben voilà il y a plus qu'à tourner
maintenant am il fait frais mais malgré
les températures négatives les
préparatifs de la Saint-Vincent
Tournante vont bon train 2 ans après la
création de
l'association je crois que ça a fait
plus de 3 mois à temps
plein de travail pour chacun alors
Lionel tiens on va en mettre encore un
peu puis après on va aller sur Mor
déposer ça le long du mur du claud
lambray 50 ans que les festivités n'ont
pas fait étape à MAEt Saint-Denis pour
cette nouvelle édition le thème est
l'art et leevin au programme de ces
journées des dégustations bien sûr mais
aussi du théâtre de la littérature ou
encore du cinéma au total neuf
déclinaisons seront à découvrir on va
essayer de
créer une grande fête mais une fête qui
se voudra en tout cas sur
Moré très très animé par la musique
par la danse par les spectacles à
quelques vignees de là les bénévoles de
chambol musini sont aussi à l'œuvre tout
doit être prêt pour le grand jour
certains sont du cru d'autres de simple
passionnés dans tous les cas cette fête
est avant tout la leure c'est que du
bonheur c'est la vie qui qui reprend
même en plein hiver là il y a de la vie
de la joie de la bonne humeur puis après
on a un petit café peut-être même
laapéro connait pas tout le monde et là
c'est une occasion de se rencontrer
voilà j'ai connu 79 j'ai connu 2003 et
puis là mon fils participe ma fille
aussi ma femme est coprésidente donc on
est à fond dedans et là c'est la
dernière ligne droite on a hâte que ça
commence et avis aux amateurs sachez que
l'association recherche encore 200
bénévoles pour profiter de
l'événement